the Archbishop of Washington is
defending himself amid claims that he
covered up for so-called predator
priests in Pennsylvania Cardinal Donald
Wuerl headed the Pittsburgh diocese for
18 years
he is the highest-ranking church
official implicated in that scathing
grand jury report on child sex abuse by
over 300 priests Nicki batiste spoke to
the Cardinal earlier this week and joins
us at the table Nicki good morning good
morning Cardinal Wuerl dealt with 32
abuse cases as bishop of pittsburgh
including the case of jack Hale the
former catholic high school headmaster
may have molested at least nine boys one
of the alleged victims told us Cardinal
Wuerl brushed him aside when he
complained about the abuse of course the
sexual abuse was horrific but the abuse
by working with the diocese was almost
as bad Paul door says Jack Hale started
molesting him in 1976 when he was 13
years old it continued until his
freshman year in college he reported the
abuse to the diocese in 1997 and even
met with Donald Wuerl then the Bishop of
Pittsburgh what did world say to you he
was very very standoffish I had a letter
as I wanted to read he would not read it
he would not open it he would not touch
it by then Hale had been defrocked door
said he asked world to pursue criminal
charges but Worrell refused CBS
Pittsburgh affiliate KDKA later found
Hale in West Virginia working as a youth
counselor what would you say to Cardinal
Wuerl today I would be very upset with
him that he did not do the right thing
at the right time we asked twirl about
dortch's claims earlier this week he
said his priest that he alleges abused
him was moved I can't speak to this
priest did you may be referring to if he
left on his own and ended up somewhere
else I don't know I don't know if that's
actually exact whirls name appears more
than 200 times in the Pennsylvania grand
jury report which also criticized his
handling of for Pittsburgh priests
involved in a pedophile ring one of
those priests George service was placed
on a leave of absence in 1995
whirl presided over his funeral in 2001
it's very difficult first of all to bury
a priest who is still so young and with
so much potential ahead of him last
night Cardinal Wuerl reiterated he
wasn't stepping down now remember we're
talking about a long spectrum of time so
how he dealt with things in the late 80s
early 90s is different than the way we
would today Paul doors the man who says
he was abused in high school once world
to resign but world has continued to
deny wrongdoing Dorsch also told us he
recently called Ann Hearst out of his
alleged abuser Jack Hale who Dorsch
claims admitted to the abuse Hale did
not respond to our request for comment
you can't amaze him we're gonna be
seeing you back I'm certain thank you